[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show it's where america hangs out to
have a conversation about your life i'm
ken coleman joined by my colleague dr
john dolone as we take you through this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the phone number to jump
in triple eight eight two five five two
two five now when john and i get
together obviously we're gonna talk
about your money questions your life
questions that you have come to know and
to love here on the ramsay show but we
will both dive into our specialties as
well if you're new to the program or new
to one of us quick summary is i'm
helping people figure out what they were
born to do you were created to work
and if you started looking at work as a
contribution where you could make the
income you desire and the impact that
you desire what would work look like all
right so we're talking purpose
and
when you're on purpose by the way in
your work watch how your life and your
relationships get much better now john
uh describe for folks that might be new
to you or to me or to us what you focus
on with the doctor john delaney show we
talk about relationships and mental
health and parenting and education and
trying to just figure out life yeah
anything um
above and around and to the side all of
it it's all trying to figure it out
that's right so john and i love to team
up if you're in a really toxic situation
feel like you can't spend another day
at the office with a co-worker or a boss
and this is serious stuff john because
it affects your livelihood you know
you're not making a paycheck decision
lightly
john and i'd love to team up on those uh
we're looking at the data man we're
looking at it people are struggling and
they're struggling at work they're
struggling at home struggling
relationships struggling their kids back
in school and a new harvard business
review uh publication uh did some
harvard research 9 out of 10 people john
9 out of 10
americans say they would consider
making less money to do more meaningful
work
what is that what does that mean
philosophically for us
for us as humans in general i i mean it
means that we all want to make a
difference and you get to the point
where you feel like i'm not doing
something that i really really enjoy and
the enjoyment isn't because it's easy or
it's smooth
it's because i really love the work
itself i'm doing something that i enjoy
doing you look at the old guys i always
go to this example who just love
tinkering on engines
it's a problem for them it's a new
puzzle you know and the narrative i grew
up with was the goal of work is to
just take care of yourself amongst
that's the amount of dollars provision
but it's past provision now it was about
it's i would think of that old garfield
poster
whoever ends with the most toys wins
yeah and that's the narrative that's
what's the area yeah it's gone from
provision to stuff yeah and what we all
know is humans it's not about anything
it's about significance we want to make
a significant dent in the world meaning
we've got to go i just want to make my
mark if we're going to really simplify
it and i think when you get people going
i'm working too hard i'm working too
long crappy environment i would
literally consider making less money to
do something that really mattered to me
that i enjoyed first
parents do it and now they say
i shouldn't have traded that for your
child well there's no question yeah yeah
so now there's a group of people saying
i'm just gonna cash out yeah nine out of
ten a group yeah ninety percent yeah
yeah huh so
now again they didn't say they were
going to do it right all right but
they're going with the right opportunity
but to your point you do they're at an
emotional place to be able to answer
that survey that way they're going i
really would yeah and you know it comes
down to it comes down to
um at some point
there's enough pain associated with
their current lot
in life
and from the work standpoint to where
they go i would adjust i'd sell my house
you know i would state yeah
my costs i just want to get off of this
hamster wheel where i feel like i'm
spending spending spinning for no reason
and you know this when people want to
either get out of debt
uh they want to find a job they love
they want to lose weight they want to
fix their marriage they want to fix a
crisis in parenting at some point the
pain gets to a place as david said many
times where you go i'm sick and tired of
being sick and tired yeah and i think
that's what we're seeing in that poll
well it's um
who wants to be sick and tired for 40 to
50 hours a week
well i mean that's what it boils down to
in
the way i've begun to distill it is we
have an opportunity to choose choose
your heart yeah it's gonna be hard to
remain a hundred pounds overweight and
have every part of your body hurt every
time you get up and it's gonna be hard
to lose 100 pounds and that's the truth
it is and it's gonna be hard to go to a
job you hate 60 hours a week and it's
going to be hard to adjust your
lifestyle down make a little bit less
money move to a new town of a lower cost
of living
it's not a matter of choosing between oh
this one's going to be simple i don't
have to i can be unstructured and not
intentional versus this one it's a
matter if you're going to choose your
heart and i think people are opting out
and saying
this is hard and it's killing me that's
going to be hard it's going to be life
i'm going to take that one yeah you let
into beautifully i was going to ask you
to talk about this because i deal with
this every day on the ken coleman show
people calling in and when i dig into
why haven't you done it you know what
you want to do you're clear these are
the people who know what they want to do
uh and they actually know how to get
there but but fear is holding them back
and i've just found this is the human
condition we just would in some places
sometimes
rather be miserable than uncomfortable
well and i used to think that was a
moral and character thing you know i
mean it's it's this it is a choice it
all comes down to choice yeah
but
man our neurobiology solves for what we
know yeah it solves for homeostasis it
would rather
the devil you know than when you don't
know exactly right and so yes that
person's abusive but i know where
they're abusive and yes this boss treats
me like crap but i can count on it yeah
and it's stepping out into that unknown
that we our bodies try to solve go back
go back to where you know so true go
back to where you know so we just stay
put and then and then you do get to a
point where you're too miserable
unfortunately usually it's it's a crisis
that pushes you over the edge and then
and you speak to this this is the world
you're in says you're trained in this
yeah the problem is john is once we get
to the crisis
you know there's so much other
collateral damage yes like even when we
go oh crap
crisis massive heart attack or whatever
pick the category health whatever mental
health
we don't want to get to that crisis
moment john because there's a whole lot
of derivative effects and collateral
damage that's when your kids wear it
your spouse wears it and your colleagues
wear it and your neighborhood wears it
yeah and that's when your mortgage
company is calling you and your entrance
i mean it's when all that stuff happens
and so yeah it comes down to one simple
thing choose your hard and then how far
upstream can you get to solve for some
of these things yeah
we talk a lot about fear you and i both
i mean we we deal with people every day
that are in fear uh myself included
right i'm not i'm not are you kidding me
you do this yeah oh yeah no by the way
fear and doubt never leave us no this
concept that you can completely remove
them is silly you can overcome them yeah
you can power through them but you will
deal with them you make peace with your
life yeah
i think fear tells us the truth
sometimes and fear lies to us a lot yeah
you know and and i i you know where's
the delineation for you on that what's
your process my process has become other
people
what i know is that when i become afraid
my brain responds and it takes part of
itself offline the rational thinking
part offline and it is simply responding
to stimuli and so
i i
have people in my life that i call and
say here's what i'm looking at and
they're an expert in money they're an
expert in life they're an expert in
marriage and um i'll ask am i seeing
this right and they'll say you're good
yeah exactly i think i need to cash out
everything and put in bitcoin and
they'll say just stand down homie yeah
go for a walk so good and go fishing but
that's my process
i know enough to know that i'm not
trustworthy isn't that the truth and so
i'm going to call somebody yeah no one's
rational when they're afraid so having
that uh community that accountability to
run stuff off of is great all right
folks he is dr john dolone i am ken
coleman you're listening to the ramsay
show your calls coming up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just thirty
dollars a month get unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to puretalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsay show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague dr john deloney
and it is your show
uh we with john and i here we pretty
much will cover just about anything you
got a question uh about anything in your
life uh it's wide open triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
the phone number somebody out there i
john i just know somebody needs to call
they're kind of going all right i've
thought about it i've been listening to
this program and uh maybe dave would
whack me on the head but i think john
and ken i think they're gonna be nice to
me probably not we'll give it a shot
though yeah i think we will potentially
yeah it's great triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's get to the phones we're gonna
go north of the border ontario canada
where joel joins us joel how can we help
hi guys thanks for taking my call today
you bet what's up
um basically i think i'm being underpaid
at my job but i'm not sure exactly and
i'm not sure how i would find out so i
was just wondering
how do i find out and what do i do about
it yeah what's your uh title or what is
your uh what would you say your
technical position is if you were
describing that uh to somebody who was a
recruiter and say hey i do this kind of
work what do you do
um i'm a mold designer like a tool and
die
industry like a mold designer oh nice so
what what what kind of molds are you
creating for what kind of tools
um mainly for the automotive industry uh
a lot of car parts okay great and how
many years have you been doing that
um just over three now okay so um i
don't have a spiffy little website to
give you to make this super easy but i
don't think this is gonna be difficult
but what you're looking at here is is
you're looking at the what what and
certainly in canada uh you're gonna look
for uh what a range of pay is and what
we call this is this is just what the
market will bear right so what's the
market for somebody who does your kind
of work uh and for somebody who's been
doing it as long as you and then i would
also throw in there any specific
certifications that you have you know so
again i'm i'm kind of walking blind into
this kind of work i can barely put the
gas in my car so talking to a guy john
who does molds for tools every day is a
bit over my skis however you know
whatever the industry certifications are
whatever kind of training you have that
got you where you are i would include
that what you're doing is a search we're
going okay
what's the range of income what do you
make right now
uh right now i make 19 an hour okay so
we're going to look at and let's just
say you do the research and the range
for somebody that does your work that
has your certifications qualifications
and experience let's say the range is 22
to 25 an hour i'm making that up
obviously because you don't know and i
don't know but if we see that we are
below
the average then what we want to do is
is we want to take that information now
this is not opinion anymore so you've
got your research if it's from a
reputable site a reputable source and
you're going to sit down with your
leader and go hey um i've been doing
this for three years i want to keep
doing this
i would love to sit down and talk to you
about a growth plan uh and that includes
this where what are some areas that you
feel like i could get better some areas
of improvement uh what are some things
that i could do certifications or
training
or some added responsibilities around
here that will make me
more valuable to the team i want to take
on a bigger load i want to create more
value and then third how can we measure
those those two things and tie that to
my compensation because i want to grow
professionally which means i want to
grow financially that would be the
posture by which you take that
information right that's if you are
making less if you find out that you're
you know right there in the middle of
that range again same conversation
growth plan because you want to max out
john anything you'd add well joel what
makes you think you're underpaid
um
so i i talked to a few people kind of
roughly in the same position as i am and
they were all making more than me but
um
i also heard that it was kind of
bad etiquette to go around asking people
like roughly what they make so
that's kind of why i thought that
because the people that had roughly the
same amount of responsibilities were
being paid more but i only asked three
people same company i'm not yeah same
business
um no slightly a different company but
same industry gotcha so yeah i think it
can joel stay here because i want to ask
him this because you do this all the
time and joel this will help you because
this is a i think this is a broader
question
i'm hearing
people let's say you're you're a mold
maker for machine parts you make 19 an
hour and right now we're in this weird
little glitch in the matrix where you
drive down the road and it says 21
an hour at sonic with a 5 000 signing
bonus it's easy to correlate
what we're seeing and hearing about on
the news in the market
and joel i'll tell you
those kind of conversations they can
give you a ballpark but people lie to
you that's right oh i'm making 42 an
hour bro you're getting ripped off no
you're not you're not telling the truth
so i would hold that very loosely that
information you got um but can
there's this balance of i think i'm
being underpaid which is a different
conversation than
i'm not making enough money yeah which
is a different conversation with
i worked really hard and got a lot of
training in this one particular skill
and now they're paying this at taco bell
and those aren't related conversations
they are not and so we see this all the
time
where you've got this happened over the
last two years where
aside from the pandemic where we had a
big drop in unemployment the
unemployment rate has now dropped back
down we now have 10.4 million jobs
higher than we had prior to the pandemic
coming in let's call it march 2020. what
we were seeing was young people were
coming in and because there was such a
need there were more jobs available than
there were people who were unemployed
young people younger people less
experienced people were coming in and
taking a position and because of the
demand supply demand basic economics
here joel
what happened was is they were getting
paid more than somebody who had been
there before but it was about supply
demand companies it wasn't that they
thought that this younger person who had
the same amount of experience was a
better employee it was just this is what
the mark is is kind of pushing that i've
got to pay right now right so to further
solidify what you're saying these are
not all related and so what i would say
joel is is to what john is saying uh
having a conversation with a couple guys
that do the similar work and them just
being your only source that's never good
because john this is back into the world
you spent a lot of time in which is
comparison i struggle with comparison i
mean good heavens we all do and when i
look at well these guys are doing the
basic thing and they're making three or
four bucks more an hour all of a sudden
it's really impossible to look at what
really matters which is
let's say that you got an offer joel
today to be paid three dollars more an
hour doing the same work in another
company but you knew going in
that they were crappy people to work for
or they treated you like insurance or
they were horrible or or
something worse than what you have it
now let me just tell you something john
i can't tell you how many callers i've
had on the ken coleman show say ken i
took a promotion for the money only i'm
miserable now what do i do right so i
joel i want you to back out of this
conversation
keep it as far away from the 19 versus
21 dollars an hour because the
temptation is to take that three dollars
an hour multiply times 60 hours a week
times this many a month and i should be
making this much more a month and think
about that on my paycheck and then i
would buy this it's so easy going that
road back out and say
the question let me just say what i
always ask ken and you can tell me this
is wrong
did my boss is it are they deceiving me
did
i i don't even care let's say i found
out you make 200 000 more than i do
right i could say man i want to make
that kind of money but
really i'd go back and say
me and dave shook hands yeah and he
never tricked me he's paying me so yeah
i would go further fair i think that's
the right first question did they
deceive me on this right number two let
me do my actual research he hasn't done
it yet dig in and so the advice i gave
him first let's go see what's out there
and how far off of my am i on that
market average then number three go do i
love this work yeah do i value this
place do they value me these are the
quick little questions you're going to
ask and you're taking a snapshot to go
do i have a ladder here yeah because if
i go over here the grass is rarely
greener by the way
relationally professionally am i right
and i think this we're in a season now
where we're watching the world change
underneath us yes and
the heartbreaking
reality that millions will face is i
have been trained in a thing
that took me a decade to get trained i'm
an expert in fill in the blank i have
been doing this fill in the blank for 20
years yup
and technology a.i the market moves yeah
and
often we're left with two choices curl
up
and be devastated by it what to say that
was a fun run and now i'm back in the
training i'm back in the pro finding
people to find out what my new career is
going to be what's this thing going to
look like but you got to face that
reality and move on it may be that 19 an
hour was incredible seven months ago and
now yeah that's what the starting salary
at a fast food joint is you got some
hard
hard choices here's the underlying
lesson folks
the amount of money you're getting paid
really has nothing to do with your
purpose
and purpose in your work is what really
really matters phones are lighting up
triple eight eight two five five two two
five dr john deloney ken coleman here
with you on the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsay show i'm
ken coleman joined by my colleague dr
john delony and we take your calls this
hour about your life we'll talk about
your money your work your relationships
your health
mental health sleep
obnoxious co-workers
horrible leaders
family members that are driving you nuts
i mean it's pretty much just wide open
or here to discuss it incredible success
stories what you're looking at right now
there this is what we love on the debt
free stage is john and catherine welcome
hey thanks for having us you bet where
are you guys from we're from a little
town called white georgia about an hour
north of atlanta okay very good yeah i
know that area uh so you're here to do a
debt-free scream tell us how much you
paid off eighty-seven thousand five
hundred and eleven dollars oh wow eighty
seven five
not that we're counting every penny but
yeah absolutely and how long did it take
you to pay it off 28 months 28 months
and tell us the range of income we
started at about 105 000 and ended at
about 140. there we go
tell me about the 35 000 bump what'd you
do i got a promotion at work and also
i'm in sales so it's the longer i do it
you know more more commission based i
built
there you go good for you
congratulations what do you sell man i
am the national sales manager for a
company that sells uh manufacturing
equipment okay awesome all right and uh
catherine uh tell us what you do i'm a
homemaker
yeah you're the ceo of the house she has
the hard job that's exactly right that's
the heavy lifting well that is so
fantastic so what kind of debt was it a
little bit of everything we had some old
business debt from a business that we
had sold about seven years prior we had
uh some medical debt card payments
credit cards uh personal loan just you
name it we had a little bit of
everything wow so take us back 28 months
ago you start this journey what led to
this so it would have been uh so we
started in january of 2019 uh so in
december we just kind of gone through
the christmas uh the kind of the
christmas rush trying to come up with
money you know charging everything up to
our eyeballs to you know buy more
christmas presents and i think what
really hit it for me was i think it was
about a month before christmas um we
don't with the income that we made um i
went to a pawn shop to make some money
to uh to pay some of our bills and here
i was on pawning things and next month
turning around and charging stuff on
credit cards and so this is just insane
you know we uh this does not make any
sense you're making six figures
and then running upon
one of those things and catherine had
been through uh fbu when she was in high
school but uh oh great
but yeah my dad introduced to me and so
at this point uh take us to this what
you guys are a mess
do you say
hey i remember this class what happened
basically i was like you want to live
debt-free and he was like yeah
and she brought it up to us again i had
listened to dave ramsey in the radio a
few times just kind of hurt him you know
flipping through the uh-huh so i started
listening a little bit more and trying
to get into it and we said you know what
january is a good time to kind of start
fresh and we uh go through that process
but we were we say we were kind of
dave-ish until about march of 2020 okay
we were definitely still going on the
journey you know we've done the you know
the step one and we done we were working
on step two uh but it was not as gazelle
intense as it should have been and then
march 2020 with the pandemic did
something happen in march of 2020
the whole world burned down and you came
back together again
so uh we went through it we got really
gazelle intense then so at the height of
our uh journey um we were not only was i
working you know my regular job but on
the weekends i was delivering pizzas i
was also doing um two side gigs uh both
buying and delivering groceries we were
selling stuff on ebay we had always had
a large garden so we we set up a farm
stand we started selling uh where she
was canning goods we were selling
jellies and jams and our own produce and
we were working five or six different
things just to really have any money we
could get coming in to really speed it
up so that like a large portion we paid
down came from march of 2020 until may
of 21. yeah that last kind of the last
leg of it my goodness so you had a great
salary
and paying off 80
87 90 000 y'all were really running lean
we were yeah and what was the most
extreme like take us to we just heard
how intense you all were from a work
standpoint you guys were getting after
it bringing in more money but talk about
the sacrificing the abstaining side of
things how crazy did you get well i am
switched from buying clothing and things
for the children at um like retail
stores to go into consignment and thrift
stores to borrowing from friends and
hand-me-downs
um did the kids survive did they make it
oh yeah they did they made it no way
yeah and then um we switched our cell
phone providers to something much much
cheaper
and you know just write some beans rice
and beans yeah we we cut cable we you
know we went to uh we did that you know
we also did uh then you got to play with
your kids and talk to each other
yeah right we did lots of things like
that we also um you know we went from
buying like uh you know quote-unquote
like you know healthier food like you
know some of the more organic stuff to
where we went to uh you know buying all
generics into aldi and places like that
really you know we saw just switching
grocery stores we knocked our grocery
bill down by like 600 bucks a month yeah
which is crazy um so things like that
yeah um yeah we just made a lot of a lot
of little changes a lot of telling each
other no you know hey we kind of want to
do this thing well it's not the budget
and uh you know we can't do this month
or let's look at it next month and uh i
think the biggest thing for us through
it all was really improved our
communication skills because for even
though you know we were you know we're
sharing bank accounts and everything
else uh our money was often running two
different directions you know we had
goals for ourselves not necessarily um
family yeah that we weren't talking
together about as much and you know at
this point we've been married you know
six years we began this journey so we
should have already been on the same
page but it kind of was in different
directions so this really helped us pull
together and we did you know every
dollar together every month and sat down
and uh i think the first probably eight
or nine months she hated that time of
the month and then we kind of got better
as we got used to it yeah and making
adjustments and uh you know learning how
to work on a budget and and
things and we dealt with setbacks i mean
we had uh we had about twenty five
thousand dollars in medical bills we had
a cash flow through the beginning of
this yeah um so she had had some major
surgery so we had to do some of that and
we also had um how to buy a new hvac
system we had to do the dreaded hvac
yeah it always likes to show up when
we're trying to make headway financially
what would you say to couples out there
that aren't on the same page they're
hearing this and they're shaking their
head they're going we're not on the same
page financially you guys got on the
same page what would you say to
encourage them
i mean i think
just uh finding your finding your why
getting your goal and then really just
finding a way to communicate you know i
had to adjust how i spoke to her about
money because um if i wasn't careful the
way i spoke about money came off to her
like i was either being condescending or
was uh or i was not value was important
to her because we had different we had
different things are important yeah and
i think i mean from your end um
basically
i've been very privileged my whole life
so being told no was not really exciting
but um
you know
not really learning to live like within
your means and below your means to make
sacrifices really was rewarding
um
you know it's a good feeling to be able
to look back and see what i've
accomplished yeah that's awesome so uh
who are your cheerleaders who are the
people that really cheered you on and
stayed with you through the journey
definitely our family our families um
you know her parents especially in mind
too as well but um you know her you know
her parents who are the ones who had
centered through fpu back in high school
you know they were followers of the the
program were kind of encouraging us on
and um you know and our and uh you know
my uh my dad's stepmom as well we had
some good folks and uh from family and
friends in our corner from friends from
our church were really encouraging as
well
that's awesome and the kiddos i see that
they're here with you we're going to
bring them up in just a moment but did
they get it like were they were they
kind of in tuned and how did they
contribute well they uh after saying no
to so many things and then for so for so
long we figured we had to kind of tell
them why at some point we explained the
concept of debt and they were like well
why would you get into that that seems
silly like well yes
you know out of the mouths of babes come
wisdom right yeah so um but uh they but
they started to understand what we were
doing and they were excited for us and
we're talking about it and then uh
sometimes they would tell each other or
um and our oldest who's with his
grandmother today but you know he'd
remind him no we're not doing that
because you know we're because mommy and
daddy are in debt like we're working on
stuff and so uh
they kind of helped police each other a
little bit so it was good well i see
they've joined us so tell us who they
are and their name their names and ages
please this is ephraim
he has seven this is lydia he has six
she is six there you go we got it ephram
and lydia that is so awesome and now
have they been practicing their scream
are they ready to go yes sir all right i
think it's time don't you john let's say
we're going to give you a copy of the
legacy journey because that's the next
step that's where y'all are headed and
we're going to give you a copy of total
money makeover so you can give it away
to somebody who you think would benefit
from and change their life as well yeah
so please pass that along all right here
we go john and catherine ephram and
lydia they paid off 87 000
uh 87 511
actually in 28 months making 105 000 to
140 thousand dollars let's hear your
debt free screen all right guys
three
two one we're debt-free
i love it so good
way to go kiddos they nailed it that's a
happy family john
it's quite a sacrifice yes but it's two
years and now yeah every single thing is
different two years you're right
i mean game changer that's it a little
bit of storm a little bit of hustle for
peace
and an unbelievable future ahead of this
young family beautiful beautiful
whatever they want great stuff he is dr
john dolone i'm ken coleman and you're
listening to the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague john
dolone and we are here to take your
calls about your life your money your
work your relationships mental emotional
health whole nine yards let's go
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number triple a eight two
five
825-5225
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
make sure you use the promo code ramsey
to get the best deal
so today's question comes from marissa
in michigan i'm 28 years old and
currently at the end of what has been a
very long and tiring phd program as they
most of them are
my goal has been to stay in academia
where i could teach and do research but
i discovered along the way that this is
not the path for me for a variety of
reasons i've lived very frugally and
worked on the side so i have no debt and
75 000 in savings and investments wow
way to go marissa
i've worked over 70 hours a week for the
last six years and i'm exhausted i've
lost interest in any work to related to
what i've studied and i dread entering
the workforce only to do more of the
work i've grown to despise
what should i do wow
there's a whole lot here i'm gonna
simplify this john i know you'll add to
this but i would start with because of
your financial
uh i would call it freedom uh i think it
would be good for you to go do some job
just any job forget and i'm the guy
that's always pushing people to find
their purpose and find that dream job
which is simply about using what you do
best to do work you love that produces
results that matter because you're so
fried marissa on this type of work i
think you go try something totally
different and just if it's just covering
the basics the bills but you've always
been intrigued by it and you're just
going i want to do this work because i
think it'd be kind of neat kind of fun
or i just want to help these people and
get a paycheck i keep it really simple
and i think that's the first step of
kind of coming off of this
this this uh deep fryer we use in the
deep south where we throw anything in
and it's just hot burning grease and
it's bubbling and i think she's been in
that so long then i would
make sure i start
re-examining what caused me to feel
fried and lose it i think there's a
whole lot of circumstances john that we
can't get to because this is an email
question but i would examine do i love
the work still if i wasn't in that
cauldron that boiling cauldron of
pressure maybe some toxicity a whole lot
here we don't know about
and the way i would do that is by myself
i'd spend some time just getting alone
under a tree in front of a lake quiet
and go
why did i love the work originally
and if i removed all the negative yuck
would i still love the work and then the
third step i would say is and this is
tactical you can help out on the
emotional advice and everything else but
i'd get with some people who
do that work
and they're really fulfilled and very
happy yeah i just spent some time
talking to them and go what's your
environment like
and i would do all of that to see if the
heart is telling us it's time to move to
something totally different because it
could be
or the heart's just damaged and it's
wounded that's my quick take yeah and
anybody who's finishing i love like the
deep fryer and who's coming out deep
fryer you getting done with the phd
program it's been very long oh my god
you should be burned out i can't only
i'm fairly certain that my wife likes me
on most days and my kids
and there are some days when she says
i need to go away today yeah i need to
go away for a couple of days right so
just because you need a break i love
that idea just go get a job go get a job
and it's almost like a pallet cleanser
yeah go put your head into something and
you can because you've worked really
hard yeah and
man you were you were dead on working in
academia at a big research one
institution is different from a teaching
college different from a faith-based
school from a community college do you
hate teaching do you hate students do
you hate research do you hate chemistry
like get clear and you can only get
clear when you've got some space that's
exactly yeah just back out a little bit
but just because you're fried doesn't
mean you're crazy it doesn't mean you
have chemistry right or editing or
whatever you got your phd in yeah it may
just be you're exhausted yeah yeah and
again i've taken so many calls from
teachers who thought at the start of the
phone call can they start off by saying
ken i need to get out of teaching i have
no career what to go to help and when we
dig in we find that they're a teacher
they have a part of the teacher they're
put on this planet to instruct if we're
going to make it simple and now we've
got to find a different environment
because maybe the environment you're in
for reasons that they go through isn't
the best and they go oh it's not but
they find well public school environment
isn't for me but community college i
would love it or trade school or go to
the corporate world and be a trainer
which is an instructor so
um
it's tough man yeah because it's so hard
to see clearly john when you're just
trying to keep your nose above the water
yeah sometimes i imagine a doctor it
feels like that
like you're just the waters up here yeah
and as hard as she's been working on the
side oh on top of everything else that's
right yeah yeah well we appreciate the
question
all right let's go to baltimore maryland
now where jayla joins us jayla how can
we help
oh good afternoon how are y'all doing
well we're having a blast what's going
on with you jayla
thanks for taking my call um
i'm currently a sophomore in college
debt free due to a scholarship
and i pay nothing but i'm somewhat
restricted into one business school mind
you i've always had a passion for
automotive and mechanical engineering
throughout middle and high school
due to my fear of debt
and making my parents proud i took the
scholarship rather than going to the
university i've always wanted to go to
and my question is should i stay at the
university i'm at
due to my fear of death
or go to the university i've always
wanted to for the major i naturally have
a passion for i don't want to end up
regretful and unhappy in a career path
that i'm good at but do not enjoy one
day yeah
well first of all young lady um
i sense a little bit
maybe you're beating yourself up a
little bit yeah because you did this
thing you're like i made this choice to
make mom and dad happy and to not go
into debt and i you're a sophomore in
college so you are not at this
crossroads where you've wasted any time
or effort i just sense that on you is
that true
yeah okay but don't can i ask you a hard
question jayla
well let me let me piggyback what ken
said i've never heard anyone
in all my years working in college
saying you know what i'm really mad
about my free undergraduate education
i'm so ticked off about it what an idiot
and um so you have a passion but you
mentioned something that's a red flag
for me after working with college
students
do you really
not want to do business
and do automotive engineering
or
do you have your eyes set on a
particular university
that may have a particular person or two
or three that go to that that's the
question what's the answer
well yeah i knew it
i knew it wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait okay wait wait i think it's the
right question doc but i want to know
because you said at one point you've
always had a passion for automotive
engineering and then it was this we
heard twice this universe that i want to
and you're absolutely on it so jayla
where is it at is it 50 50 is it 60
university 40 engineering where are we
it's more so like
60 percent engineering and 40 university
because the school i go to now they
don't have an engineering program at all
okay okay so that's committed all right
so we have very limited time so we're
going to cut right to the chase okay
because the heart of your question is do
i have to stay where i am in a
scholarship for a degree i don't want or
take on debt and that's a false
narrative yeah yeah okay so i want to
head that off here's what i teach and
john agrees with me you need to do the
engineering work or you will regret i
mean you've you've nailed this at a
young age that you don't want to be in a
career and wake up at 35 and go i didn't
do the thing i wanted to do you like
solving mechanical problems you like
cars and the whole automotive thing
that's where you want to be you've
identified that but here's the deal how
many different pathways are there to
that future that's the homework
assignment that i'm going to give you
because you can answer that better than
i can but do not assume that you've got
to take debt on to get there because
that's garbage and it's not
true you hear me
yes so here's the question you got to
ask
what degree do i need or do i need a
degree and i think you do to do the
engineering you need a degree so
who are all the people that offer that
because let me just tell you this
anybody that's going to hire you jayla
is not going to care where you got your
engineering degree from am i right john
most of the time yeah
i set you up to where you just had to
disagree they don't care nobody cares
they want to know if you can do the job
so jayla it's where else can i get it
you can't get it where you are you're
gonna have to have a hard conversation
with mom and dad because i know they
want you to to go to school but you're
gonna say i'm still going to school but
i gotta change my plan so where can i
get it how much is that gonna cost me
how do i save up for it maybe can i get
a scholarship for that i'm gonna work as
hard as i can to get into the school i
need to to get the degree i need to do
the work i want to do no you can do this
no death that's a false narrative you
got this jayla thank you so much for the
call hey wow that hour is over thank you
james childs thank you kelly daniel
thank you john deloney and thank you
america this is the ramsay show
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show it's where america hangs out to
have a conversation about your life i'm
ken coleman joined by my colleague dr
john dolone and we're here to take your
calls this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five triple eight
eight two five
five two two five doc how are you doing
today you good you're right you're
standing that's right we got a full
stretch full crew out here in the uh in
the lobby yeah i saw you back in the
hallway doing some uh some uh exercises
with the throat none of that happened
but this did happen yeah uh we we greet
people a lot on the show
and i was brushing my teeth after lunch
trying to be a good neighbor and
community member
and i don't know how this happened i'm
so excited you're telling this this has
never happened never i grabbed
a tube of hair gel yeah
and i brushed my teeth yeah with hair
gel how long was it in your mouth before
was it like a half a second an eighth of
a second a tenth i'm still struggling
with my taste and smell so i was
thinking this isn't right and then i
thought george campbell played a trick
on me so you had that thought while
still brushing out here this is not
right hey how many doctorate degrees do
you have i forget yeah we don't do taste
testing in grad school this is called
being highly distracted
and i can't criticize him because
honestly it feels like that's something
that i would do but we're keeping an eye
on him folks because i'm half worried
that any moment james he kills over
because i'm pretty sure there's a
warning on the hair gel bottle which by
the way whose hair gel was it and who
uses hair gel still well we do
share an office with we share a dressing
room with george campbell that's a whole
new hair products back there there was a
hairdryer back there's a whole thing but
i thought you're going to blame it on
dave that's another show dave is not a
hairdryer guy believe it or not but
he's not a hairdresser anyway i hope he
makes it through the rest of the hour i
don't think you're supposed to have that
in your mouth it's got your help i
dropped my body weight in listerine and
i think we're good okay good but it was
not great very good all right to the
phones we go we'll keep an eye on him
folks i think he's going to be all right
angela joins us in lexington kentucky
angela how can we help
hi um thank you guys for taking my call
and actually hoping that ken you would
be on the show today because my question
is uh specifically for you okay um
and i work with some
young adults and kids i'm a little bit
older than them so i call them all kids
um
and i am trying to
mentor them kind of sort of um to stay
away from debt and things because i
don't
want them to have the same regrets that
i have you know graduating college and
going into you know their lives as
adults um
and so i
here on the show sometimes you telling
people kind of
um what kind of questions to ask
themselves as far as careers and and um
like their purpose in life and things
like that and so
i'm setting up a uh library budget uh
day kind of with some of them and so i
wanted to ask those questions um so that
i can kind of give them a better idea of
what they want their futures to look
like because some have an idea some
don't
um and some are just choosing college
just to choose college and i'm like no
don't do that yeah well so let me give
you a very basic set of questions that
really uh is it's the whole methodology
that that i teach and this is how
someone gets clear and this is how we
take this big giant idea of purpose that
seems so intimidating and so mythical
and so hard to figure out and we
simplify it so here are the questions
what do they do best
what do they do best that's talent every
person on the planet was born with
talent they'll acknowledge that so we
want to just begin to have some fun
conversations with them let's not make
this big career-oriented conversation
take the pressure off of young adults
because they don't have a ton of life
experience so we just start talking
about what do you do best hard skills
soft skills right so for one person they
might be really gifted
artistically right
another person might be very good
mechanically what do they do best that's
a hard skill then the soft skills
otherwise known as people skills so
you've got hard skills and people skills
what do they do best uh then the second
question is
what work do you love to do now
again the younger the person
the uh
the more exploration they're going to
have to do on this question because they
don't have 10 years of work uh maybe
they don't even have a degree yet as
you've talked about they don't have a
major so they're still trying to figure
it out but what work do they love to do
and i would break it down to task and
function you know you think about doing
work one day
work that you think might be enjoyable
or even in high school uh if you begin
to wonder about it or you saw somebody
else do something you saw them at career
day even as an eighth grader you went
that's interesting we want to begin to
have the conversation and say what kind
of work do you think you would enjoy
doing just the task
or the role itself and then finally
what results do you want to put out in
this world and all work create results
so this is fun for somebody young
because now we get away from career
titles we get away from paths we just go
what contribution would you like to make
to the world through your work and
there's there's a three-part question
within this one okay i know i'm hitting
you with a lot of questions but this is
the key
these questions allow people to make
everything personal
and so they dig
who are the people they most want to
help
and when they begin to think of the
people they most want to help they can
also identify this what's the problem
they have or the desire they have
doesn't always have to be a problem
could be a desire
you know a 19 year old could say you
know i want to help people that have a
desire to look beautiful
and so they could turn into a whole
career esthetician cutting hair you know
but whatever makeup artist whatever
clothing designer so personal trainer
personal trainer so we're looking at who
are the people i most want to help the
problem or desire those people have and
then what's the solution to that problem
or desire that i most get fired up about
now when we start talking about that
third little part the solution to the
problem or the desire
then the ideas about occupation begin to
kind of surface and more importantly
what i'm giving you here is a
conversation starter
and then a conversation returner have
these conversations over and over have
them put out real answers have them then
talk to men and women that are that are
doing the work that they're kind of
throwing out there as maybes and i think
the younger that you can get them
thinking about this and exploring and
discovering and talking to others that's
going to be really really good and i
would point you to our get clear career
assessment we've got a 20 minute
assessment online
that if you're 19 18 19 you're still
going to get some good from it even if
you don't have a lot of work experience
and you can get that at
ramseysolutions.com and that's a
wonderful little tool that'll give them
a purpose statement a working purpose
statement that's not in stone but they
can begin to have a more detailed
conversation that's great yeah so i
appreciate the call and john i you know
you you
you were in the education industry you
know part of the thing that i think
i'm trying to fight
through our traditional education model
and this comes from culture and parents
and parents are kind of getting it from
culture is that we're sending kids off
to colleges that have massive amounts of
pressure to pick the right major
and and just figure it all out and get
the absolute best job right job out of
college i get that there's nothing wrong
with that but to me where we're
eliminating the discovery that i think
needs to happen from 18 to 21 and just
diving deep on that simple of a
conversation you know i remember when my
son was in was in first grade
they were talking about what college
you're going to go to yeah it's nuts to
me i was thinking he's learning
numbers dude right
right i was 35 i don't know what i want
to do with my life back you know what i
mean so yeah the pressure we put on
people from ages six to yeah
it's just bananas so that little simple
process is just about by the way what
you just said about i want to help
people look their best you can become a
chemist you can create the weight room
equipment you can run a gym you can
there's a thousand ways to solve that
problem that's exactly right good stuff
all right folks triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number
your call's coming up next this is the
range
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show thrilled
that you are joining us my name is ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
deloney we are ramsey personalities
thrilled to be with you this hour as we
take your questions it's about your life
your money your work
uh relationships your health the whole
nine yards we are here to help you out
and uh i want to remind you that work
isn't a four-letter word it doesn't
have to suck it really doesn't we are in
this great resignation where people are
considering changing jobs and changing
jobs because they want meaning in their
work
and our proven plan has helped thousands
and captured all the details
uh of the seven stages to doing work you
love in my new book from paycheck to
purpose the clear path to doing work you
love you can pre-order today it is a
proven clear path that will walk anyone
in any industry with any experience
through the step-by-step plan to finding
meaningful work now if you pre-order
today you get our get hired bonus pack
for free which includes the resume
templates the get hired digital course
uh streaming access to our from paycheck
to purpose live event a 30-day free
trial to ramsey plus and so much more
that's over a hundred dollars of free
stuff so if you want to do work you love
and make the move in 2022 go ahead and
get ahead of the competition go to the
online store at ramseysolutions.com
and pre-order your copy of my new book
from paycheck to purpose today for only
twenty dollars when you do you get all
that other amazing free stuff so go get
it ramseysolutions.com
all right the phone number is triple
eight eight two five 825-5225 let's go
to kansas city missouri where earl is
waiting earl how can we help
thanks for taking my call basically
the question is this i'm a minister
and i work in a non-profit organization
um
my question has to do with this uh you
guys have a have an ethos there in in
your
uh with ramsey solutions i have a
christian culture because i i hear you
guys use a lot of phrases and whatnot so
i can use some language that so when i
say a servant chart you know exactly
what i'm talking about
my question has to do with
what is the relationship of any
between having a servant's heart and say
not receiving a promotion that you
thought or you should have received
or being demoted
from the position that you're in if your
employer says yeah this is this is what
happened but you need to have a servant
chart about this
how exactly
is that process within
that mode of thinking where are the
lines how does that fit together so you
know so you were demoted in a on a
church staff and and and they said you
need to handle this with a servant's
heart is that what i'm hearing
i'm i'm about possibly to be demoted
yeah so i'm just
i'm just trying to why are you being
devoted
why um
changes in administration above me
but but why are you being demoted
other than changes with folks above me i
don't know i'm not exactly sure i mean
is it is it are they cutting back
discipleship i'm sorry is it cutting
back on costs they're trying to they're
going a different leadership direction
they don't you're not um performing it
to the standards that they want it's
saying a new a new leadership team came
in
there's more to it than that right
and be honest
what happened was
basically an administrator
um one position above me
put forth a promotion
for me
to do a different job okay so right now
i run a whole
i run a whole program for men okay
if i was to take this if i was to be put
in this position i would only
i would like do one third of the work
that i that i was doing before i'm
trying to be vague just in case okay i
got it um so it's not a matter of my
performance i can assure you of that
but this one person
put forth this
uh this idea that we can put this person
here
and then we can have four people doing
case management
because right now i just don't do case
management i do everything i
teach a ton of classes i i do so many
different things so but are you being
asked to do more work for less money or
are they just edging you out i'm i'm
confused at
what's happening i was trying not to be
too specific because because the time
constraint okay well
okay go ahead
so so basically
there's a different program where
clients go to
for nine months after my program my
program is six weeks long okay basically
i assess
what caused the homelessness usually
it's addictions or mental disorders okay
or a combination of both or other things
then for the next weeks uh next six
weeks i take care of
discipling them telling them about
christ teaching having them classes
classes on addiction classes on many
many different things okay i help them
get all the things they need to be
prepared for the next so is is the
church saying that we don't want to do
those things anymore
no the church is saying we want to take
your program
and the next program and put them
together okay so you no longer will run
this program but you'll be a case
manager right now there you go okay all
right so right now i run the whole
program right so earl here's here's my
take on your your initial question
john you weigh in here but earl
uh it feels manipulative to to me to
that's christian ease i grew up in the
church so i feel like i can say this
um
you can have a servant's heart you
should have a servant's heart we should
all have a servant's heart okay
but you still have a heart and this is
the motion and you don't like it and
it's obvious and you don't have to like
it now what you have to decide though is
they've made this decision sounds like
it's being made
and i've got to decide
can i serve there
can i get my head and heart right after
i deal with this disappointment and do i
feel like i'm supposed to be there do i
feel called to this particular place
versus i know the work that i love to do
and what i'm called to do so i don't
like the way it sounds uh because the
bottom line is this feels kind of crappy
and uh you're gonna have to decide do i
wanna stay here because of this now
don't leave because you're hurt i think
you need to leave if you feel like
the work i'm supposed to be doing the
work that i'm challenged by i'm not able
to do here anymore so i'm going to look
elsewhere but to answer your question at
its simplest form
how do you process that
you can have a servant's heart and still
think it's pretty crappy
yeah be heartbroken and be angry and
pissed off and frustrated the servant's
heart part yeah and i agree with you
it's manipulative that's just nonsense
yeah it's manipulative nonsense i hate
that crap
the reality is though you can have all
those feelings and experiences you still
have an obligation to treat people with
dignity and respect that's right and you
still have to deal with reality yeah and
the reality is you worked really hard
this was your baby you loved it and
a new group of managers came in and said
we're gonna we're gonna contract
everything together and move you into a
different role and so heartbreaking it's
hard sad it feels personal it's going to
be vulnerability shame all stuff
and you're going to say
uh i appreciate you being honest with me
and telling me that and i've got some
decisions to make that's right ta-da
yeah and it's harder it's more complex
than that but it's not it isn't and
don't blow up the bridge but you know
the
you don't have to not say you know or
push back and if there is some and if
and and i
i'm reading into this john i am too i've
been there too i hate okay but
if the decision has yet to be made and
if they were just going you need to
handle this with a servant's heart and
they're going don't push back well don't
ask questions or you can ask questions
and you should and you can still have a
humble spirit and you can be civil and
ask questions and push back but it just
felt like to me it was a blanket
statement yeah that was just like hey
dude here's the deal yeah you don't get
any say in this
um which i understand leaders have to
make decisions
but to put up don't kill
when you make a business decision in a
non-profit and then you wrap people's
human reaction and make it a moral or
spiritual issue drives me crazy because
it's weaponizing yes thank you it's
weaponizing kindness it's weaponizing
the gospel it's weaponizing yeah um
humanity don't do that if you're gonna
make a business decision look at
somebody and say you've worked really
hard and we appreciate it we're going a
different direction
and let me just throw a shot at leaders
out there don't you dare whether it's a
faith-based organization or not don't
you dare treat people like crap and wrap
it in the flag of the cause so stupid
it's nice she got me all fired up here
earl thinks i was having a great
wednesday and then earl calls
i'm glad you called man thanks a lot
yeah earl you'll get through this man do
not let this decision in any way define
you and treat people with dignity and
respect brother no matter what happens
he is john dolone i'm kid coleman this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show where we
take your questions about your life your
money your work
relationships
and so on and so forth i am ken coleman
joined by my colleague dr john delaney
we're taking your calls it is a free
phone call triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five and uh through
the uh very heavy glass here in the
studio in the lobby i see john over
there on the debt free stage john
welcome
thank you it's good to be here i
appreciate it where are you from
pittsburgh pennsylvania pittsburgh all
right all the way here to do a debt-free
screen yes fantastic all right give us
the numbers how much debt did you pay
off 184
673 dollars
and how long did that take uh five years
oh wow and give me a range of income uh
started at 54.6 and right now i'm just
shy of 90. hello
talk to me about that what did you do to
get the uh the old jump in the pay uh
well uh hard work got a couple
promotions uh with a prior job and then
uh covid was one of the better things
that happened i got furloughed for five
months and laid off with about two weeks
notice and uh now i have a better
position uh making a lot more money a
great culture and uh it's just kind of
happening so wow congratulations yeah
it's true that the income definitely uh
goes up as you're going yes sir you've
got a much bigger shovel that is a
beautiful thing all right tell us about
the debt what kind of debt are we
talking about it was mainly student
loans 118 2 of it was student loans
i had a jeep payment i had a home equity
loan i had two credit cards
uh and then i had a couple medical bills
uh some home repairs i know you
mentioned earlier someone mentioned
their air conditioning went out mine
also went out so uh not a need uh but or
not a want i should say but oh yeah it
worked out what did you study 118 000
worth of uh not as much as you but uh i
my undergraduate is so you have friends
and relationships fancy you know what
i'm saying no but you have a social life
real cool john a little bit yeah who
knew um undergrad is in hospitality from
penn state and my master's degree is
from robert morris university with in
human resource management okay okay
great and what are you doing now i'm a
corporate trainer oh yeah so i work for
a healthcare robotics company good for
you yeah awesome
wow so
five years ago you start this journey
what led to it what was the the
catalytic moment if there was one
uh my mom and i we i've been in debt my
whole life and um i actually got very
fortunate i got a promotion which was
going to make me travel 80 of the time
so i realized i said
companies gonna be paying for 80 of my
expenses where's all this money coming
from and uh i learned of dave ramsey and
i took fpu in 2012 and as you say i
failed it
i didn't really uh really do i did the
barely even dave ish and when i got the
new job i sat down with my friend
kristen and i ended up being her first
client
did my first budget i had fifteen
hundred dollars left over
and i said
where's this money coming from that was
august 11 2016 and i said where is this
money coming from and she said you're
putting it on paper before it happens
and
light bulb it just it just went off and
i said i need to do this i didn't have
any hope up until that point and um once
it you know once i did that and i had
that much money left
it yeah it's on it was awesome kristin
was a financial coach uh she wasn't i
was her first client and now she's
full-time i was actually here for
enrichment ken
we talked uh and john you also pointed
to me yesterday yeah so oh yeah i
remember your question you got a little
bit of emotion right there yeah yeah
thinking about it what's that coming
from
just it's it's it's finally happened you
know and and i'm there and i can i can
now
you know do some things that i haven't
really ever been able to do yeah like
what and uh
well
not worry for one there we go that day
as soon as i did that budget i paid my
first credit card off it was 996 dollars
i paid that off the next day
and i had had that for years i couldn't
pay it 25 a month i couldn't pay it and
i paid the next day and it just blew me
away so not worrying about money it was
completely gone uh i use every dollar
every single day i just bought both of
your books back there by the way that
was a good decision i wanted to i hear
it was i hear it was yeah so um and uh
you know debit card those credit cards
are cut up uh i i think what are you
dreaming about though i i just censored
some big old dreams yeah if our two
books are the top your dream list you're
not dreaming big enough brother they're
close they're they're they're yeah
they're close they're close
uh you know
i was in enrichment this week and one of
the things we talked about is go from
here to there and dreaming and having
those goals set up and and
it's a lot
um it's very high on my priority list
just to not have that money worry
i am very fortunate i've had very people
very fortunate in my life to help me i
like to give back so i'm very involved
in my rotary club and my masonic lodge
so being able to give back and that you
know outrageous generosity to me is very
important
so that's one of the things i really am
looking forward to doing and increasing
as i move forward
and and
i know it's kind of cliche enjoying life
but man
some of the things that i know i can do
down the road and and helping people and
some cool vacations uh i may or may not
want to buy an 82 or an 86 jeep cj7
come on man
we'll see we'll see i love the classic
cars yeah yeah so
that's one of my dream cars so i'm
looking forward to some things like that
a little bit of material but most of it
is just being able to give back and have
you had that moment where all your bills
are paid and
the check deposited and you're just
staring at it in your online account
have you had it prior to all of this no
no no when did you hit hit send on your
last payment uh december 10th okay
mother's birthday oh
september september 10th about two weeks
ago oh okay so
you haven't had the october check that
the whole thing lands and you got
nowhere to send it not yet um it hasn't
really it's all yours man and here it is
yeah that's gonna be a special moment
very cool yeah we're proud of you
brother absolutely so talk to people
what's the key in your mind for your
journey to get there uh number one is
the budget uh i mentioned every dollar i
use that all the time even if you're not
using that find a way to do the budget
and stick to it and and for me it's
constant motivation and and
uh having those accountability partners
my friend kristen recupero she and i
talk very often when i'm kind of
struggling uh and frankly i listen to
all of you here i listen to podcast
every day and it just kind of helps me i
tear up a little bit and get good
goosebumps when i hear all the other
debt-free screams there's one earlier i
heard and gave us some high fives so
that for me to help keep me going is
saying especially being single it's nice
to have that those accountability
partners in your life friends and family
and and some people quote-unquote
perfect strangers on a radio that i
haven't met until recently talking about
their stories so to me that's that's
very important well i love that yeah
dude there's something about the
community mm-hmm yeah it's everything
right
other people are your emergency fund for
life yeah did you get involved in a
class at some point in this journey as
well i took fpu and 12 as i mentioned
and then i'm also a coordinator i have
another class starting october did you
take it again or you just kind of
remembered it all and you were like i'm
going to make this happen i just
remember it all i still have all the
materials yeah just just listening to
the podcast it kind of helps remind me
of that and then obviously coordinating
i'm basically taking it again so that's
awesome yeah well thank you for doing
that that is so great so you've listened
to a lot of debt-free screams i have i
have and you've gotten chills
and some emotion and now you're standing
there on the stage this is a pretty big
deal well here's the deal we want to
give you two things uh we want to give
you a copy of dave's book the legacy
journey because that's the next step in
the chapter for you really about
building legacy and you already kind of
begin to detail how you're dreaming
about how the how the impact is going to
change from your life because of your
financial freedom and then we're going
to give you a copy of dave's wildly
best-selling book total money makeover
for you to gift to somebody else and uh
we were really really excited that you
came here to do your debt free scream
you ready to go i am you've earned all
my life you've earned it all right here
we go
john
uh from pittsburgh pennsylvania paid off
184
thousand dollars in five years making
fifty four thousand to then ninety
thousand dollars john this is your
moment let's hear your debt free screen
i'm gonna break your microphone here
let's do it bring it on homie let's do
this two one
i'm debt-free
we need a chair and a table to break
don't you think john that would have
been fun what a great story hey john
mentioned ramsey certified financial
coaches he did we got a bunch of them in
the lobby that's right so if if you were
wondering hey i want someone to walk
alongside and i know it's embarrassing
to say i i hear how to make a budget i
get it it's a math problem and it's a
planning problem i need someone to walk
alongside me i don't want someone i can
text throughout a week go to
ramseysolutions.com and look up ramsey
certified coaches they're an incredible
crew of people unbelievable they will
walk alongside you in your journey and
you will end up here in nashville
tennessee on the deaf free stage that's
right john and i had the privilege of
speaking with uh that group at a great
event here this week uh as well as
getting to hang out with them and they
are on the front lines man they have
incredible men and women who have truly
the heart of the teacher they walk the
journey and they'll help you they are
invaluable great great point go get
yourself a financial coach it is a game
changer everybody needs a coach all
right don't move for the ramsey show
coming right up after the break
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show america
where we talk about you
your life
where you want to be your hopes your
dreams your challenges we are here for
you i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague john delony and it is a free
call for you to jump in triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five if there's one thing john that 2020
taught us about is investing it's this
you can't do it alone you need somebody
in your life who knows the market better
than you and helps you make smart
decisions uh we both love
do-it-yourselfers right i love these
shows i'm always jealous of these folks
that can do anything themselves because
i barely can you know just to get
dressed and get out of the house is is a
big feat for me but when there's a
global crisis if you try to do it
yourself and you invest in the wrong
things you get caught up in the trends
you're going to make rookie mistakes
and if you build a portfolio based on
what you read on reddit oh my word folks
you don't need the unnecessary stress
like that in your life so
never again let your investments be at
the mercy of some global crisis get some
people in your corner who know what
they're doing text the word invest to
three three seven eight nine text the
word invest to three three
seven eight
nine all right to the phones we go
billings montana
whitney is there whitney how can we help
[Music]
i have a question on our business side
of things okay so
husband and i have a trucking company
that we started a year ago
and we started out with a ten thousand
dollar semi and just him and i and
we have a trailer payment and then we
bought another truck on top of it and
we are have 20 000 on the trailer
44 000 on the new truck
and
in personal trucking or in the trucking
right now we have
33 000
and
i'm wanting to pay off the trailer but
wondering
if that's a good idea or not
why would it not be a good idea we
believe in paying off all debt you don't
want to be underneath that so
what's
um
work is
work is definitely busy but relying on
income
on a personal business i think sometimes
you're waiting two to three months
before you get paid
you just gave me more reason why you
should not be leveraged owing other
people money
you guys just started this thing
why do you have two trucks
keep one going
so you borrowed money for two trucks in
a trailer
one just in case something happens to
the other one
and so you know the first truck is paid
off the first target was we only bought
that ten thousand dollars
paid cash for it and
it's an old truck you know
i mean
that might break down a lot
okay but if how much is it how much does
it cost you to fix on average you've got
some kind of track record here where you
can say well over the last three months
we spent x amount of dollars on repairs
to this truck
the last three months on both trucks
we have
we have put in over 40 000 in repairs
over i'm sorry did you say 40 000
yep
for what
uh
a rebuild on the motor um
differentials on both of them
uh
eight pumps on one of them and it never
occurred you
occurred to you to sell one of these
trucks
oh well we can't when one's broke down
and we're using the other one as income
so you don't even have the cash to fix
the one that you own outright am i
getting this right
oh no the one that we own outright is
still running okay then the one that we
owe on is the one that is broke down and
we do not know why it is
so whitney here's what you've got
whitney hold on you all have created a
big giant mess
and now you're spending
precious energy precious relational
capital precious money
trying to solve this mess that y'all
created
and well and then there was another
wrench thrown in the plan our
oldest son is diagnosed with brain
cancer
that's right
it's a it's
there's too much chaos in your world hun
to have all these payments and all this
well we need to keep this one in case
that one breaks down and then the one
that you got as the emergency vehicles
the one that you're spending 30 grand on
it's a lot yeah
but to answer your original question yes
sell one of these trucks
pay off your trailer owe nobody anything
even if it cost you a day or two in
earnings
just do the math on what it costs to
hold another truck
uh without any earnings against it
you're just got too much the one that we
owe oh yes is the one that's broke down
that's right sell the truck yeah you're
gonna have to
you gotta slow down you gotta back out
of this we gotta fix this you guys
jumped into this thing and you had some
mechanical problems i get that i mean
that's murphy's law it happens um but
you have so much else going on and that
that little boy is everything to you
guys
and this trucking business
is not the only way you all can make a
living
so
i know you got a lot going on but i want
you to consider that wait a second we're
gonna have to circle the wagons as a
family and go through this incredibly
i i don't even understand what you're
dealing with i couldn't possibly unless
i had walked through it but i just know
that there's other ways for you all to
make money and if we have to press pause
on the trucking company or we scale it
back to the one that is working and
we're just going to only do what we can
do there we have got to get stable and
you've got to get this debt cleaned up
and you got to get out of this thing you
guys can always get back in it you can
always ramp it back up but do it cash
like you did on the first truck i would
sell that second truck pay off the
trailer yeah and you're gonna have an
old truck that's yours
and if it breaks down you know anybody
any money in the gap
and but right now it's not breaking down
it's the newer one that you bought as
the insurance against the old one that's
breaking down on you and like ken said
you've just had a tornado you get a bomb
go off in the middle of your home which
is a really scary diagnosis
and this is going to take some clarity
some clear thinking some simplification
of a whole bunch of stuff because now
you're going to get a real clear picture
of what matters and it's that little boy
and like ken said if that means one of
you has to take another job that's got
health insurance one of you's got to
stop the dream we have on the road
everything changes now you are all
different now everything so you got to
sit down and say where are we who are we
and then what's
the little steps going to be look like
moving forward yeah and please hear us
neither one of us said whitney that the
dream is dead we're saying we got to
scale back or pause completely we can
get back on this thing you've learned so
many lessons from this but yes get out
of debt get this thing cleaned up as
quick as you can and uh there'll be
another day the storm is over you right
now
and um you got to deal with the storm
and we don't need to add any elements to
the storm it's bad enough as it is
that's uh heartbreaking john i mean it's
it's hard to think clearly too you know
you got all this complexity this
business this brand new business it's
still a baby business yeah and all of a
sudden your baby
comes down with something that just
shocks everything your whole world yeah
shocks it i tend to over complicate
things
by trying to over plan for contingencies
which is a
it's a fear of losing control
and then
a good example is you know having 50
different passwords for every
login and making sure those are all
written over here and that password is
over i end up making everything so
complex that i can't function
and that's a simple obnoxious way but
they started an awesome business they
had a dream and my guess is that
somebody made fun of them about their
old truck
somebody was like that's what you're
driving or that thing's gonna break down
you better be ready you're gonna lose a
big load and so they got enough of that
in their year that they wouldn't bought
a truck that they couldn't afford
and then that's the one that's broke
down keep things simple when you're
starting don't owe people money people
don't understand how freeing that is
yeah and um yeah get a group of people
around you to rally around your son's
gonna be in it for the long haul yep but
i will tell you there are options folks
yep there are options to make more money
to get through any money crisis you need
right now so go to work do whatever you
got to do and stabilize and give us if
we can ever help you with you give us a
call yeah absolutely all right i want to
thank our producer james chiles our
associate producer kelly daniel want to
thank my colleague dr john maloney i
want to thank you america you're the
reason we do the show this is your show
it is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rebel studio this is the ramsey show
it's where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money we'll talk also about your work
your relationships the whole nine yards
we're here to help you and give you hope
and a clear path forward i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague john delony the
phone number to jump in is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five
five
two two five let's go to austin texas
where michelle joins us michelle how can
we help
thank you for taking my call so
i had a question just regarding my
roommates situation
the past year has been a real roller
coaster
and
the lease is coming up to an end on
sunday
my uh roommate isn't uh communicating
with me and hasn't paid her september
rent still and it's the 22nd now so i'm
just and she's blocked me so i'm just
wondering how to kind of go about this
situation
um
and like i don't know if i should
confront her in person or yes what
really to do
i'm gonna jump ahead in front of john on
that one yes literally my question was
is she still sleeping in the same place
brick your door like how do you block
somebody in real life y'all live in the
same room and you answered it for me
should you talk to in person god
almighty please help all of us yes yes
um so i've actually moved out um and i
think she's moving the rest of her stuff
out today but i know you're guessing
just go over and have a human
interaction a polite respectful
dignified one and if she acts like a
maniac or a jerk you can say hey
you don't have permission to talk to me
that way um here is a letter that says
here's your notice that you're going to
be moving out and then you have peace in
your heart and you go around about your
day but you have so much chaos in your
heart because you don't have real
information because you haven't had a
real human conversation with another
real human what happened yeah um like
what happened what happened with you two
to where you feel like you can't just go
hey look we don't have to like each
other uh we're certainly not gonna live
together anymore but can you be a big
girl put your big girl pants on and pay
your part of the rent like what happened
to where you're so terrified of that
um
she's just a very
mean and ugly person i've confronted her
about things um in person before and it
got really ugly so like that's kind of
why i'm i'm scared yeah so let me let me
say this are you are you unsafe
um just like just her words are super
super hurtful okay
so there's a there is a middle ground
between no communication
and the words you use you you've used it
a couple of times which is to confront
the gap in between is just a
conversation yeah
that can start instead of hey you
haven't paid rent what's been going on
why'd you block me
hey are you okay
how how are you i haven't talked to you
in a long time and i want to
i miss talking to you are you okay
i care about you yeah
in one of those conversations your body
responds it dumps adrenaline cortisol
into your bloodstream you start uptaking
glucose because your body's ready to
fight somebody and there's a you don't
have to get there
if you're not safe
if you think you're going to get hurt
physically don't show up there
when you took on a business arrangement
with somebody you took on that
discomfort you need to have that
conversation and if she says mean things
you can turn around and walk away in
person and say you're not going to talk
to me that way thank you very much yeah
and then be on about your day yeah and
here's the deal
john's absolutely right and if you do
all the things he tells you and she
still comes at you hot
you can't fix that no she's trying to
make this difficult for her own reasons
and maybe some of she doesn't even know
why she's doing it that's john's area
but i'll say this
i would stay very calm and say look
there are repercussions to this i'm
going to pay my part you got to pay your
part i'm not going to bother you ever
again i'm not trying to get in your
business i hope you're okay i hope
you're okay i i'm so sorry for anything
that i've done just go real blanket here
really easy and just go hey
we just you need to do this thing so i'm
just trying to facilitate you let's get
a clean fresh start
and if you've already moved out yeah
then walk away if
you've moved out and you signed this
lease and subleased it yeah then you owe
that money yeah you can
sue her for it you can go through all
the drama or you can learn a hard lesson
yeah and you can move on about your day
yeah and and again you hear me again our
voices check like
you can get amped up nobody makes good
decisions when they're amped up calm as
contagious
coming in low as you possibly can and
say here's the reality of our situation
and let's move on with their day yeah
yeah and and
john let me ask you this because from a
professional standpoint
when she does that she takes the power
away from this gal this gal's definitely
made a power play the nastiness and all
that whether she's hurting or not it's a
power play yeah and it's working i mean
michelle's really really hurt that's
right she's shaken up i'm not gonna give
i'm not gonna give somebody that level
of power over my life i agree i'm not
gonna let the guy driving next to me who
i is just cut me off i'm not gonna give
him access to my blood pressure i'm not
yeah i'm not gonna give him access to
being angry and yelling at my kids when
i get home because i'm all amped up and
fired up because someone didn't drive
the way i wanted them to i'm not gonna
give them that access to me if they put
me in a position where they want to
fight me i'm going to walk away because
i'm a grown-up you know what i mean like
i'm not going to engage in that that's
just a waste of my time and energy and
so i get to control what i'm bringing to
this situation and the only other option
outside of that is i need to get
something out of that house and i'm
going to be i am in danger of being
physically harmed that's right then i'm
gonna bring the police away that's right
yeah other than that i'm just not gonna
give people access to me in that yeah
and that's what and so if that's easier
said than done but we've got absolutely
we've got to detach ourselves in this
situation michelle's got to detach
herself from all the mean and hurtful
things and realize she's playing me yeah
i don't have to know everything i have
to be a psychiatrist and figure it out
what i do know is she's playing me she's
been nasty i can't fix that i need her
rent or else i'm on the line
a lot of folks who
get engaged with somebody who's nasty is
whether it's a boss whether it's a
spouse whether it's a
roommate
and we spend a lot of energy
wondering why what it is about us that
is invoking the nasty
what is it about me that is making you
treat me this way
and that's a wrong way to approach a
relationship issue that's me thinking
i'm deficient and i'm trying to get you
to solve it and the uh the way to flip
that on its head is to say i'm a person
of dignity you're gonna treat me with
respect and you're not gonna talk to me
in this way
and if you are yelling at me that means
you've got an issue not me because see
that's great does that make sense
it's not my problem to solve for you it
makes total sense but i think that most
of us screw that up
yeah if you have a boss that's treating
you like a jerk you kind of go away
now if your boss calls you in and says
the work you turned in is garbage it's
not good you need to up then that's your
problem to solve yeah but if they yell
at you they belittle you they act like
that's their problem and the decision
from this point over is your choice to
make right that's good boy that's really
good and that's how you kind of take
that attack it's not giving you that
let's sting so much and since this is
the ramsay show you know an awesome way
to detach yourself is not owe anybody
anything and have a fully funded
emergency fund yeah and don't rely on a
roommate if you don't have to i'm gonna
walk away that keeps it pretty
good stuff all right folks don't move
more of your phone calls coming up
he is john dolone i'm ken coleman and
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show where
you
get answers where you get a clear path
where you get hope to move forward in
your life we're thrilled that you've
joined us i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague john delony the phone number
to jump in is triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to raleigh
north carolina where trey joins us trey
how can we help
hello trey
all right
we will put trailers
trey's like i'm thinking about this
question for a moment and uh i'm too
impatient so now let's go to
um oh is trey back is trey back all
right we're gonna try it again hello
trey
hey how's it going guys
fantastic how can we help
good good um i need you i need a little
bit of help here um we all do man we all
do what's up and i'm in the
security industry and um i've managed to
you know get great
well with city job um great benefits and
pay and after about two years i realized
that i'm in the wrong role
i'm not able to
showcase my best skills um i've applied
for those particular jobs and promotions
and
um wasn't selected for an interview
not even within my own department
but with it being a state you know job
and benefits and the pay is higher
um here than other companies in my area
um for what i do
um i'm 25 and i don't know what to
what to do but i'm not happy in this in
this role okay well let's start with
that you're not happy in this role which
you know there could be a myriad of
reasons um but let's focus on the big
reason are you not happy in the role
because of the environment the people
around you maybe your leader other
things there's not much opportunity
there or you're not happy in the role
because you really truly want to do
something else there's something missing
in your work
what's the real driving force
yeah i would say that it's uh it's it's
so there's some things going on um in in
the environment um but
i think for the role that i do
i'm more of a human to human interaction
you know i love helping people um and
i'm just not able to
you know to do that um kind of just in
one spot trey i know this is kid's kid's
sweet spot but
a lot of security positions especially
with city is got a lot to do with
seniority is the fact that you're 25 and
you've been doing this for a few months
or a year or two is that playing into
these folks who are getting these
promotions have just been there longer
than you
or have you got some feedback
i'm not good at this you don't have the
skill set yet
um one of them came in around the same
time as me and uh well we came in
together okay um and they were you know
they kind of
you know got
you know we're promoted and um things
like that and
um you know i pretty much give
everything well not everything but i
give a lot 110 percent um you know to
the job and
yeah that's stressful but here's the
deal
you don't have the juice
you like doing people-facing stuff my
guess is you're you're good at people
skills right you love people you like
working with people you're good at
people what would you say to that yes
absolutely all right then so if you're
doing that and you know you're not happy
i'm sure you've let your mind wonder a
little bit
not wander
i mean wonder what are you wondering
about what would you do what would you
try
where the it's kind of where the hiccup
comes i know i deal with this all the
time but but don't hiccup hiccup means
you've had a thought or two but then
something derails you i just want you to
know without any kind of fear of failure
or anything else what would you try
tomorrow i said try not commit the rest
of your life to what would you try if
you knew you couldn't fail it was people
related work
what would you do
oh man um
i would help the youth you would help
the youth now we're getting somewhere
help you tell me tell me what kind
what's going on how would you help them
what would you be helping them with a
desire they have or a challenge they're
facing
um i would say i would say both um i
i've gotten a lot of feedback from you
know from people with being my age and
you know saying that i have a great head
on my shoulders and
um you know not into a lot of you know
different things i kind of think things
through before i
you know before i do them and look at it
from all angles so let's get more
specific a lot of people have come to me
good so let's get more specific i want
you to tell me when you said youth you
had a snapshot in your mind it was a
polaroid all right now i want you to
tell me what are the problems and
challenges they're facing the desires
they have be super specific give me 30
seconds on that go
um just not feeling as though um you
know they can they can make it you know
out of their
particular situation okay what situation
is this poverty is it abuse alcoholism
in their home talk to me
yeah i would say you know i would say
poverty um you know or because they grew
up a certain you know a certain way um
that there isn't a better way okay out
there all right now i want you to keep
feeling your answer you're doing a great
job
i feel like we're in your heart here
we're not in your head i don't want you
in your head stay in your heart for a
moment
where are those kids at
where are those kids hanging out in
raleigh north carolina who's serving
them
a lot of them are
on the streets
yeah a lot of them just are scared yeah
where are they though are they in public
schools in certain areas or are those
kids you've got a good snapshot of them
are they hanging out at the ymca are
they hanging out with government
programs talk to me where are
they um a lot of them actually i'm a big
goer of the ymca and you kind of hit
that one right on the nail around the
head oh that was a total yeah a lot a
lot of them yeah a lot of them are are
there okay all right now we're gonna
move really quick i want john to jump in
too but how much money do you make right
now
um about 40 about 40 000. okay 40
thousand dollars all right here's here's
the exercise for you okay and i didn't
tell you you're gonna do this i said
this is an exercise i want you to have a
homework assignment to look into
how many jobs
in the raleigh north carolina area pay
near forty thousand dollars it could be
45 could be 38. i want you to to just do
the research
where those kids are hanging out who's
serving those kids so i look at the ymca
and i go is the ymca hiring if they're
not hiring doesn't matter what are the
positions at the ymca what do they pay
because they may not be hiring now but
they may hire in six months and i'm
gonna get over there and use the
proximity principle uh what government
programs local municipality county
government state government uh maybe
some federal fund what non-profits
christian organizations are serving
those kids and what positions do they
have and what do they pay that's where
you at least have to start are you
tracking with me
yes sir because if i told you trey
that john could call somebody in raleigh
north carolina today
and you were going to be serving those
kids
and you were going to make 40 000
how quickly would you say yes to that
in no time in the blink of an eye
there you go
so
trey i'm not saying this is going to
happen overnight probably won't
may not happen in the next month or two
but can you get into this kind of work
where you are loving on kids face to
face knee to knee
and pouring into kids that you've got
some connection to
is it possible trey that you can make
forty thousand dollars
or change your lifestyle to be able to
do it and live comfortably on thirty
five if you were helping those kids can
you do this trey
yes i could are you going to do it
yes i am
my man
ken how many people do you see get
trapped with this is what i do
in his case i work security yep and then
they try to
cram
who and what they love doing through
that lens
instead of as you just put you just
unbraided it for him
really what you want to do is help kids
yeah you can do that as a high school
basketball coach you can do that as in
the ymca social
social worker is a counselor you can do
it a thousand ways or one of the ways
you can do it is being a police officer
working security
but
take the lenses off yeah and reverse
engineer this thing yeah but it really
comes down to who are the people you
want to help yeah what's the problem
they have
or the desire they have i had my house i
wanted to help people with mental health
and i
i only was looking at it through
colleges and i'll never forget dave said
john right now you helped thousands
what if we wanted
you want to help millions yeah and it
changed my picture i'm doing the same
thing i'm just in a different kind of
different environment it's always about
who are the people i want to help what's
the problem they have that i want to
solve what's the solution to solve that
problem that fires my soul up stop
making it so specific all right don't
move more of your calls coming up this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the ramsey show continues as we take
your calls
about your life i'm ken coleman joined
by my colleague john dolone the number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five that's triple a eight two five
five two two five how many times in the
past year
have you heard someone say i just wish
things would get back to normal but what
was normal like for you were you worried
about money
too much to do not enough time to do it
you shouldn't have to go back to that
when there's so much
better ahead for you but to get the life
you want you need the right game plan so
ramsey solutions got a free live stream
event on september the 28th entitled
game plan live dave ramsey christy
wright george campbell will be laying
out the clear plan to make all of your
money goals happen like how to find a
vision that gets you excited
setting healthy boundaries that keep you
focused you can have the abundant
balanced
debt-free life you want and it all
starts at game plan live to register for
this free live stream text game plan to
33789 that's game plan all one word
two three three
seven eight nine
all right uh let's go to ben in chicago
who is on the line to do a debt free
scream ben how are you
i'm good how about you well we're doing
good but you're doing great
so talk to us how much debt did you pay
off
i paid off 45 177 dollars in 15 months
wow getting it ben way to go man come on
man now what was your range of income
during that time
started at 45 000 and got up to 63 000.
so 63
wow what'd you do to get the bump
uh i got a promotion which helped with
most of that and then also i was doing
some side work repping some jiu jitsu
events oh nice reffing jiu jitsu events
what just curious what does that pay per
event or is it an hourly thing how does
that work
it's per event so it should be in the
range of like 175 250 depending on which
event you're going to i love it and what
do you do for a living
i work in marketing so i'm a sales
analyst for a children's book publisher
awesome so i'm just curious give me the
quick version of how what you did to get
promoted
yeah so i started there just more in
like a general role
uh which was just kind of like as a
sales assistant and within that role i
was
doing some side work i was trying to
figure out where there were some holes
in the company where they could use some
help with things and i had a pretty good
background in excel so i was building
some reports for them and they realized
that i had a skill with that so when our
role opened up for a name for an analyst
job in the amazon team
like you know ben did really well with
this other stuff i think he can help us
here nice i love it man now john that
right there is maximizing your role he's
looking for other areas to add value to
the company and it led to a promotion he
didn't sit there and whine and say why
aren't i not getting promoted i'm not
getting promoting look for a whole
solves it and it feels like vanilla ice
yeah i checked out the hook while the dj
revolved it good for you nice i love
anytime we could get vanilla ice in a
show our work is done here uh ben that
is so fantastic man really proud of you
okay so tell us what was the debt
consisting of
uh about 5 000 of the 45 was for a car
loan and the rest was student loans okay
great 40k all right so what kind of car
you got
uh 2017 hyundai elantra all right
come on now all right so 15 months ago
you're a young guy
uh what led to this debt-free journey
for you what was the catalytic moment or
feeling or circumstance what happened
yeah so earlier than that i was just
getting an audible subscription i saw
dave ramsey's name come up a bunch and i
didn't find any of his books then but at
least i like recognized like this guy
seems to know what it's all about in the
financial space so he had a free podcast
started listening made a lot of sense so
i was like you know what i think i'm
actually going to go after this and do
what he's talking about
awesome and so how quickly into the 15
month journey did you go oh this is
definitely working i i got some momentum
i can do this
i mean right away i had about ten
thousand dollars in savings so just like
getting down to baby step one and seeing
the car go away immediately was pretty
nice yeah you're a jiu jitsu player
you're always thinking three or four
moves ahead right
and you know how to be uncomfortable to
uh accomplish a goal that's fantastic
which incidentally uh ben uh how long
would it take you to wrap me up in a
pretzel
i mean
not long dad i'm just telling you right
now you're not gonna hurt my feelings we
know the answer how quick is it like 20
seconds no chance three at the most
three seconds
you're a good guy i would have no reason
to do that oh no i thought it wasn't
about that it was just how quickly can
you do it you're being very nice
uh okay ben so uh you got the jump start
on the ten thousand dollars you knocked
the car out so you really did get a big
jump start
what would you say to somebody young
who's dealing with just the kind of
normal debt that you had what would you
tell them
yeah i mean
it seems like it's not that big of a
deal because you're just looking at it
in terms of payments but when you
actually look at how much you're paying
to interest which you're basically
getting nothing out of that
um
you got to see how much you're paying an
interest and it's going to make you mad
and you're going to want to pay as fast
as you can so you can limit how much
interest you're paying because you're
really not getting anything in exchange
for it
so this is more of a somebody's taking
something from me issue and i want my i
want what's mine back
yeah
love it
yeah he's got a warrior mentality he
does there's no message that you guys do
that's why jiu jitsu is the greatest
sports unbeliever i know i knew you were
going to be very excited i love it yeah
great stuff well ben tell people what
the key is what's the key to finishing
this journey
yeah just staying focused and making
sure that you have goals to set and
things to keep you motivated so it was
nice when i had like the car when i
could pay off and it's nice when you
have the debt snowball but since i had
like a giant loan of like forty thousand
dollars and i couldn't really like
complete a loan i had to like put a
little poster on my wall for every
thousand dollars and have something to
cross off every time i crossed a
thousand dollars so it just kept me
motivated the whole way through that's
fantastic good for you man and how old
are you ben
30 years old my goodness so you are on
your way we've got two things uh two
books we want to send you uh to
celebrate you one is dave's uh book
entitled the legacy journey because that
really is the next step for you is you
become a baby steps millionaire and
you're just gonna do some amazing things
young man and create a legacy so we're
gonna give that to you and then we're
going to give you a copy of dave's book
total money makeover for you to give to
somebody else that hopefully will
kick-start their debt-free journey so we
want to do that for you so thank you for
sharing your story with us
thank you are you ready to roll oh yeah
all right this is over there's a jiu
jitsu reference there well done ken
i didn't even know i made it what did i
say
you ready to roll rolling is the
vernacular for hey you want to go to the
gym and roll that's a jiu jitsu
reference ken is a ninja everybody i am
a ninja and didn't know it
no surprise to anybody of that all right
well you're a great young man ben we're
so proud of you here you go
ben from chicago illinois paid off 45
000
in 15 months making 45 to 63 000
ben
this is your moment take it away let's
hear a debt-free scream
three two one i'm debt-free
quick like a chop to the throat dude he
got in there yeah rear naked choke
fight's over
match is over yeah yeah no time to even
tap out take down armbar yeah yeah we're
done messing around nope i love it ben
doesn't mess around at all what a
fantastic story huh
and
whether it's 45 000 or 450 000 the the
plan is the same
yeah make a decision yeah get after it
yeah
i you know i love when we all you know
when we ask that question everybody's
got
you know their different spin on it and
i think you nailed it for him it was
like wait a second i looked at that
interest deal
and he's like uh uh
i'm paying that company yeah you nailed
it what are we doing yeah i don't i
don't want my i don't want to pay them
as a service
to pay somebody else for me i'm just
going to cut out the middle man i'll do
it myself it didn't just speak to the
the crazy importance and value of
figuring out your why whatever it is
yeah if you want to get an extra degree
if i want my money yeah if you want to
lose weight yeah if you want to have
more romance in your mind you better
find that why that what's that driving
force and own it yeah because it's
powerful
i've i always i've not always i've been
wondering for the last year or two as
i've said on these can take these calls
take these calls
what's so hard about getting to why
and i think
if we allow ourselves to look in the
mirror and answer that why question
there's no going back you're right and
you burn these ships box yourself into a
corner when you see your your child's
face or the one that hasn't been born
yet or that you've got personal dignity
you need to stand up for yourself or
you're married or whatever the thing
happens to be if you sit down and you
develop a picture for why you can't go
back
there is no going back it's burn the
ships or you gotta look in the mirror
every day and say i'm choosing
i'm choosing to uh that's the truth not
love as deeply as i could
and we can't do that you nailed it get a
why it puts you through the corner
because every day you don't do it you go
yeah it's an affirmative choice to hurt
those we love
good stuff all right don't go anywhere
more of your calls coming up on the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague john
deloney and we are here for you triple
eight eight two five five two two five
today's scripture titus two seven
through eight in everything
set them an example by doing what is
good in your teaching show integrity
seriousness and soundness of speech that
cannot be condemned so that those who
oppose you may be ashamed because they
have nothing bad to say about us today's
quote
from the seventh president of the united
states tennessee boy andrew jackson
one man with courage
makes a majority
you know john i gotta tell i i'm a
history buff
kelly daniel our associate prisoner
she's a big history buff as well i got
to tell this quick story about andrew
jackson so kelly i don't know if you've
heard this story but the audience will
love this this isn't a boring history
story
i'm literally already asleep but i
continue well that's because you're i'm
just kidding go ahead so andrew jackson
in his old age as president was once
approached by a man who tried to
assassinate him in a group of people
this is in washington d.c
and the man pulled out a revolver think
about how long ago this was and click
click it doesn't fire
he pulls out a second one
and fires it doesn't go off by this
point jackson now realizes
i can take this guy he's an old man and
literally a bum rush is the guy in front
of the public with his cane and beats
the man almost to death
so there's a little andrew jackson story
if you're gonna fire at andrew j i mean
he literally in front people had to pull
him off of the guy guys trying to
assassinate the president he just goes
and just beat him it was fascinating so
i'd picture somebody doing that to dave
can i be honest
i i would see dave doing that if you
tried to shoot dave you didn't get it
you know
you know he wouldn't beat you just shoot
you back yeah i think yeah he doesn't
have a cane no no cane but i think
that's a fantastic andrew jackson story
so he was president yeah at the time he
was a
actual president when it happened this
is the old days dude it's the wild west
you know what i mean someone could just
walk up there wasn't secret service
so there you go all right uh i don't
know if anybody's life is better for
that but uh i gave it to you and there's
a great story for your next cocktail
party in tennessee uh it's a great
connector for our financial coach you
come to tennessee you meet somebody from
tennessee there's your icebreaker you're
welcome now they're gonna believe this
now they get it yeah anna is up in
cleveland ohio anna how can we help
hi mary thank you for taking my calls
um
so i just finished um i just graduated
from college in december
and i'm just i feel like i'm in a unique
situation i guess everybody does um i
wasn't able to do an internship because
of covid
and then on top of that um
i i've been looking for
a new job just to help pay the bills um
and
i
left an abusive relationship
earlier in may
and
with the relation with how it ended i
had called the police
and
because of the nature of my my ex
he fabricated a police report um against
me that i came and like beat him up and
um
and there's there i have all the
evidence in the world that i wasn't
there i could have a literal video of me
at like go walking into a hotel um
but
so i'm
i'm trying to um apply for new jobs and
like with this degree and everything but
i'm
really worried um about how i'm gonna be
perceived with this charge on my record
because um it's not who i am at all and
everybody who knows me would know that
um but i can't
prove that to a new employer and so i'm
just really not sure like
how to go about this because it feels
pretty defeating yeah that's that's
heavy and i hate that that happened to
you i'm glad that you had the courage
and the strength and support to leave
that
abusive relationship and get rid of that
nonsense you're worth more than that and
i'm glad you walked away and
unfortunately we live in a world where
anybody anytime can lob any accusation
any sort of anything against any of us
they can file a suit for any number of
reasons
and
we have to rely on the process and the
people involved in that process
so
most of the time and i say 95 99 of the
time
a job is going to ask you have you ever
been convicted of
and your answer to that will be no
because anybody can file any sort of
thing against anybody anytime
and you will truthfully and honestly
answer no i haven't been convicted of
anything
and
if they happen to say are you under
investigation for anything
and you feel like having that
conversation and you can say i left an
abusive relationship and it's currently
um in investigation right now um but i
am
everything is just fine yeah anna could
you give us a quick update john i just
want some 401. you keep going but i is
is the matter solved now and he just he
kind of put out and the police showed up
to investigate because they have to is
this thing still open investigation or
is it
um it's still going through like
pre-trial and trial yeah so it'll be an
event it'll be its own thing i got you
okay yeah and that stinks my guess is um
it
yeah depending if it probably won't make
it out of it probably when you make it
to trial i i just tell you right now if
you've got video shows that you were not
there uh unless your lawyer is a
complete buffoon and you can't show the
judge that
i want to encourage your heart john's
right that'll probably get thrown out
what kind of job are you looking for
i
well i
think really anything that pays more
than what i'm doing right now um i i
just graduated with an urban planning
and development degree but i'd love to
work with non-profit um
our
ideal i would also i have a couple ideas
in mind um
i would like to do stuff with community
development and like housing i'd like to
be an appraiser and then on the opposite
end be a flourish so
um
so
how old are you do you mind me asking
your age
yeah i'm i'm 30. okay very cool so
you've got this this mix of things um
and i think that right now
um before you search for any of those i
want you to kind of take a little bit of
time to get clear on this unless you're
just in dire straits financially are you
in some kind of a hurry to get a
different job than the one you have now
other than the fact that you just don't
like it it's a j-o-b
oh i love my job actually um and they're
super supportive and like employees of
the year and whoa they're awesome it's
just
yeah it's just not the work you want to
do long-term
it's it's more so it just doesn't pay i
only make like 25 to 30k a year and it
was the job that i just got when i moved
okay area okay but here's a good job the
reason i asked that question you
answered it you love it right now so we
don't have to be in a hurry so when i
hear
planning and urban development that's
what you went to get your degree in you
had some interest there we could at
least say that right
i don't know how much your heart's
involved with that but then we talk
about florist and then what was the
other one
um i'd like to do um appraising okay so
here's what i want you to do real estate
i want you to here's the deal i'm going
to give you a copy a free copy of of my
book the proximity principle okay
and and i want you to read it and do it
now here's the deal it's for people who
know what they want to do they're just
not quite sure the best way to get there
and you've got these multiple ideas and
it's going to work for you here's what i
want you to do okay it's going to really
hold you accountable but i want you to
go hang out with a florist or too and i
mean hang out
i mean like not just coffee or lunch say
could i shadow you for half a day i'll
actually help for free i just want to
get a sense i want to get in here and
get my hands dirty and i want to feel
what it's like i want my heart to be
able to register what it actually is
like to be a florist so you're going to
get a lot of head knowledge but you're
going to get a lot of heart knowledge as
well and i want you to do the same thing
with an appraiser you got to know
somebody who knows somebody who knows
somebody who appraises nobody wants to
shadow them trust me right so they'll
they'll do it and i want you to sample
this work do you understand what i'm
saying before we start looking for
anything else and i think that will help
you in this season with this this whole
court mess going on before we go looking
for something let's be pretty darn clear
about what we're looking for does that
make sense
yeah and anna i want to tell you
something and listen to me real
carefully okay
when you roll out of an abusive
relationship
everything about everybody
is that they're scary and they're going
to hurt you
because somebody said he loved you and
they hurt you is that right
the only way this is this is what makes
abuse so evil
the only way to heal is through
relationship with other people which
means you gotta risk again you gotta
trust again so get a group of people
around you whether it's one two or three
or four people get an attorney that you
trust trust the judge to do the right
thing
and lean back into relationship
you're worth it i'm so proud of you for
being brave now you gotta go take the
next steps great stuff
always good to be with you pal good to
see you my name is john deloney want to
thank our producer james childs our
associate producer and call screener
jenna sears and you america this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker just
tell alexa google assistant or siri to
play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
you